[Musique]
ahmed khan fesses à monsieur aulas la
guérilla à faire ça m'angoisse mais
comme jeannot angoissé ma vie à aller on
va démarrer par capucine à naves vos
bons points et vos mauvais points sur
thierry moreau anna on commence par les
points forts et les points faibles
oui merci beaucoup suivent un peu
l'émission aulas à l'émission oui alors
vous savez quoi on va voir tout en un
instant on aura le magnéto sic
récapitulatif de tirs ennemis et vous
allez voir et donc moi je me suis rendu
compte grâce à ce magnéto que thierry
moreau les télévisions
[Applaudissements]
ont été regardés on va vous montrer
merci d'être avec nous on est en direct
avant vous montrer tout ce qu'il faut
pas faire tu as quel âge 52 52 52
regardez tous il faut pas faire j'ai
regardé 50 et la musique
[Musique]
là
ma
vous faites beaucoup de peine alors
merci d'être avec nous il ya plein de
choses qui vont arriver il ya la nuit de
daniel moreau avec matthieu delormeau et
mathieu de l'amour a quelque chose à
préciser on aura le deuxième magnéto bas
sur à miami de jean michel hmaé j'aurai
quelque chose à vous préciser puisque
j'ai une nouvelle révélation à vous
faire là jean michel vous allez voir
vous allez être contents
thierry moreau c'est votre conseil de
classe il y aura les quatre tirs de joie
du club camille combal aussi qui
arrivent on viendra sur la faire quand
tout ce matin sur europe 1 on fera plein
de choses s'il vous plaît beaucoup et je
vous donnerai mon avis sur vous et votre
note attention c'est parti
capucine à nabeul avant de donner votre
note est votre appréciation vous
connaissez thierry moreau bah évidemment
mais aussi qu'elle aura les crocs acérés
au fond de cette boîte danse les sarine
dans un seul et services
il est lourd a donc amputé chanter moi
je prends toujours la vie de mon épouse
et après je valide avec mes enfants ma
charge des pouces ça fait 27 ans que je
m'endors le soir et que je me réveille
le matin avec la personne que j'aime et
j'aimerais qu'il arrive la même chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la croisière à l'est ou en tant qu est
ce que vous connaissez l'histoire du
pingouin qui respire par les fesses non
et bien un jour il s'assoit il meurt
je vais vous donner des blagues
d'ailleurs vous savez comment on y
châteaufort château
[Musique]
voilà bon on est tous affichés mais on
aime bien quand même à les capucines à
naves points forts pour faire les bons
et ben justement son point fort pour moi
c'est son humour parce que trop fermé
blague à part si ils n'avaient pas cet
humour il n'en serait pas là aujourd'hui
au chili et au combat du coup se passe à
son point fr dont n'ont pas les idées
ben voilà même moi je trouve que son
humour au contraire c est ce qui le rend
attachant et vous fait rire vous tirez
vous à une ferveur parce qu'il est pas
drôle mais du coup c'est un point fort
et son poids fait pour moi c'est que
pour l'émission il est peut-être un
petit peu trop gentil avec avec tout le
monde pour les patrons télé 7 jours
aussi bien patrick sébastien qui arrive
donc ça me changeait un peu plus lorsque
vous êtes encore très drôle donc je vais
me la note de 8 parce que non
[Applaudissements]
avec tout le monde je trouve que c'est
un petit peu le gendre idéal
ouais je trouve non mais je trouve bien
aimé il est toujours propre sur lui et
pour moi elle s'avérait tu sais pas
l'automobile et bah ouais je trouve que
il a toujours le lapd invest le contrat
de jean michel maire lui les propre sur
lui jean michel mercier propre sur les
autres oui les salles sur les autres
préfèrent alors ce qui fait que je mets
un 8 la semaine dernière j'aurais pu
mettre un set mais pourquoi j'ai mis un
huit c'est chez moi ça va s'arrêter
combien je finis juste parce que je
crois qu'il ya un petit magnéto
justement parce qu'il ya un truc qui
m'avait touché et contrairement à nous
tous tirés quand il regrette quelque
chose qui dit ici bas il s'excuse
d'employés cote à la fin quand il a tort
il s'est excusé c'est pour ça que j'ai
mis un 8 parce qu'il est honnête et
sincère
j'adore pour une fois qu'on touche à
léry médaille alors mon thierry tu as
faim alors pour les points forts tout à
fait déjà une entrée fracassante en
septembre avec une nouvelle chronique et
ça bravo c'est à dire que tu es bosseur
tu t'endors passante et laurier
oublieuse la chronique à titi mazak
remarqué titille les chiffres défilent
c'est lui qui les trouve en tout cas ils
les portent bien
je trouve qu'il est vraiment bien oui ah
oui menteur si on en voit ça on en voit
les yeux dans les yeux
non il travaille ensuite on les yeux
j'en envoie en général cinq ou six à
emilie elle en rajoute quelques-uns
quelquefois parce qu'il ya des chiffres
qu'elle elle trouve deux sont restés à
la fin à la fin vous faites lesquels
ceux des mines et où les vôtres ce que
vous demandez qu'on fait mais bon il a
quand même s'ils s'imposent est énorme
et j'aimerais acteurs on en redemande et
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on a fait des
sondages
il est plébiscité l'attend mais il est
très bon renfort merci alors point
faible évidemment la lourdeur des vannes
et moi ils me font rire personnellement
ça me met dedans dans le lot suivant le
seul qui ait effectivement je trouve
qu'il ya parfois un petit caractère un
peu effacé quand on aboie un peu plus
fort que toi
du coup tu bosses le ton et tu te
laisses un petit peu bouffé par certains
comme à ma gauche par exemple ou en face
de moi là bas
tut tut tut appartement où on a on a un
peu parlé plus fort que toi tout d'un
coup tu mets les chiens aboient la
caravane passe
j'aime à bois la caravane passe c'est
vrai c'est un beau podium far away
scemama choix je vous le dis voilà les
raisons je tenais à 100 mais il a déposé
on aimerait avoir maintenant
l'appréciation et la note isabelle
morini bosc
alors je vous le dis si vous nous
rejoignez vous allez rien comprendre
elle écrit pendant des heures mais on
comprend vraiment ce qu'elle dit alors
bon soir vous rappelle de change les
règles tous les matins à peine si
j'étais pas clair voilà surtout en cdi
et ça coûterait cher à la ligne au bout
de 10 ans et 10 bref d'être cédée depuis
combien de temps la rd 922 en plaine de
211 tonnes en cdd pendant 9 10 ans et en
créant teddy vous croyez vous faire
l'entretien d'embauché
l'adhésion
allez on y va d alors capucine part de
bienveillance moi j'ai un petit doute
là-dessus en tiendrait le détester parce
qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de me débiner
quand il parle notamment avec
jean-michel à cissé faire quand même ses
coups en douce quand il a besoin et
parce qu'il a des fixettes comme par
exemple julien lepers donc on sait pas
pourquoi il l'a pris en ligne de mire la
triche est aussi sur les films les
chiffres de questions pour un champion
en version samuel y tiennent néanmoins
comme chez le caractère mieux avec la
figure j'avoue que j'aime ses blagues en
f1 mais oui elles me font rire il a
parfois un certain courage intellectuel
et puis moi j'aime bien son côté france
rurale le compote du dimanche ça j'adore
ça puis la collection de crânes aussi
bref comme moi je sais faire la part du
feu entre sentiments et ressentiments
je lui mets 6 alors ses points forts
c'est que sous des dehors nous mais bon
c'est sûr si l'inde et partout
pas de prix partout sur le titanic il
aurait survécu et le point faible une
des tests qui se sont même pas si c'est
pourquoi mais en tout cas il a tort
alors sourire un p'tit truc non mais
c'est vrai parce que tu as un vent dans
la série qu'on dit souvent la légende
veut que vous détestiez tous les deux ça
fait combien temps que travailler
ensemble maintenant tu passerais il est
arrivé avant dans nos mairies mais pour
moi ça fait en 4 x 4 en 5 ans et serrez
vous vous détestez enfin moi ces tests
même c'est qu'on n'est pas d'accord sur
nos analyses on partira pas en vacances
mais c'est pas grave
ouais ça mais vous avez compris ils sont
contents de se voir et ils se respectent
oui il a mal tourné à tous jusqu'à hier
je suis à bloc donc je me mets 6,6
pratgraussals mode à calais jean luc
lemoine
alors thierry compétents presque trop le
prof
mais ce qui m'amuse c'est de critiquer
ces chiffes en deux mots compétents que
je peux encore changer la donne et et ce
qui est marrant c'est qui est très
premier degré sur les chiffres qu'on
l'est d'ataq ces chiffres il supporte
pas qu'on mettre en cause sa compétence
journalistique
après au niveau de ses défauts il ya il
pratique un humour dépressif même lui
n'y croit pas mais c'est assez bizarre
parce que il veut pas faire certaines
choses dans l'émission de peur de ternir
soudaine de son image qui fait que des
bacs pourri qui ternissent son image
donc il a le cul entre deux chaises je
lui mets 5 alors balo le point fort cci
là il a un physique de premier de la
classe
donc on lui donnerait le bon dieu sans
confession donc il nous fait avaler des
infos qui sont absolument pas des soupes
pas ses sources et son coiffeur
ça fait au moins cinq ans qui a pas une
info qui a retenu un vrai scoop asie il
y aura un prime de the wall un mi mars
ils vont faire un prime en direct pour
tous telle émission qui arrive à
m'acheter le 27 personnes à donner c'est
l'info c'est qu'on est une exclue the
wall en prime avec christophe dechavanne
sur tf1 c'est une scène impôts allez on
passe alors là les points faibles je
reviens pas sur sur tes vannes qui sont
heureusement j'ai découvert une chose
qui m'a fait profondément de la peine
thierry c'est quoi et oui en fait
thierry aurait vendu du beurre aux
allemands pendant la guerre il kft il
dénonce différents tout le temps il a
raison c'est ce qu'on appelle les coups
en douce
ouais bah non à la fin ça n'en tire ici
doit vous protéger ou protéger en show
my way en tous les cas il m'a souvent
dénoncé comme tetris et tu as triché
luis a triché web comme toi d'ailleurs
mon souci merci voilà donc à tout le
monde la regarde je résume je résumerai
audio matin c'est un fumiste sympathique
mais fumiste quand même merci allait
donner le mot
at oui cinq fax accord le courage parce
que je n'oublierai jamais qu'il a été
mon bizutage plutôt mon bizutage le
premier jour il a osé m'embrasser sur la
bouche
au risque de briser un ménage 27 ans
donc je voyais pas de risque et shopping
micro je crois qu'elle s'emballe un
petit peu daniel elle s'emballe
elle-même vous savez beaucoup s'attacher
très vite un doublé décourager les
points faibles c'est un peu trop obsédé
par les chiffres et les courbes
d'audience
moi j'imagine justement le soir avec
votre épouse ça doit être vous savez
vous le puits lui caresser les reins à
sa courbe de à 30% de parts de marché le
mexique façade est un peu comme ça mais
moi je suis bien obligé d'y mettre aussi
une baraque à frites et ses cheminées
c'est pour des brises
[Applaudissements]
avec les a gagnées excusez moi de vous
dire ça vous êtes une cheminée on africa
possédant une poche sans être un enfant
de choeur à côté alors oui alors donc
j'aimerais plus de glamour plus de
qualité plutôt que du plateau
quantitatif donc moins deux chiffres et
plus de lettres et pour ça et bien je
mets trois ans mais regardez si on
rajoute un petit peu ça fait un coeur
non et daniel vous êtes politique
vous avez quand même pas elle s'appelle
moreau vous appelez moreau il n'ya pas
ya trois classes pour donner allez on a
maintenant chinois gill et mathieu et
moi son meilleur ami dans l'émission
jean michel bayle est mon meilleur ami
c'est vrai depuis le premier jour de
l'émission qu'il 8 avril 2010 16 ans et
voilà je trouve essentiellement vers
avril demain 1er avril 2010 voilà un
très bon camarade franchement je pense
que c'est peut-être le seul que
j'appellerai à 5 heures du matin même
s'il habite à 50 bornes de paris je vis
avec groupe ne vous décrochez jamais
quand je vous appelle donc si vous
touchez pas suffire je sais qu'il dort
il est chez lui à son téléphone et
décrochera je suis sûr qu'il viendrait
que sa voiture m'aider si j'ai un gros
problème donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important pour moi car il
est fidèle en amitié il a un brin
raisonnement sens et sur la télévision
ce qu'il a une vraie culture la
télévison et s'y connait même s'il fait
pas des esclaves comme comme gilles ya
une vraie culture de la télé voilà il
est aisé la liste toujours censé me sans
faire d'esbroufé
donc ça je trouve c'est vraiment très
très bon et le seul point faible
ah c'est son look et en septembre il a
pas progressé du tout les agresser on a
tout essayé les styles ismaël ont lâché
la sphère impossible la glace mais les
dégueulasse ça te retires que de poids
je te met vite
attention on va avoir la pression de
matthieu delormeau et de gilles verdez
gilles je ne sais pas est ce que vous
allez lui m mais je sais que vous êtes
souvent sévères et mathieu il a des
analyses souvent très juste et très bien
voiture ça non je ne parlais pas de vous
je parlais d'un mathieu merci la touche
pas avec quoi sélectionnés du soc 2 le
conseil de classe de thierry moreau et
bien sûr en direct dans un instant
y'aura camille combal y aura les quatre
tiers on reviendra sur la sphère contout
qui a beaucoup fait parler ici tu es au
top tweets aujourd'hui on vous donnera
bien sûr des informations et vous dirai
ce que vous en avez pensé puisque
voulait tous réagir là-dessus vous aussi
d'ailleurs vous voulez réagir
maxime kenny de médias plus d'autres
experts médias nous a rejoint des
réactions version vacciner et pour le
moment c'est le conseil de classe de
thierry moreau n'aura votre note dans un
instant il nous reste deux notes de
chroniqueurs deux appréciations à
commencer par celle de matthieu
delormeau appréciation et dot matiti
j'ai du mal à noter parce qu'en vrai
t'es un peu comme le petit doigt de ma
main dois je les aime bien mais sert à
rien il sert pas toujours à recommencer
point faible en ce qu'elle a dit daniel
n'a pas dit ça hier soir alors que
derrière la tête de la roma oui on va ce
n'est pas mon petit doigt avec
et je jure je suis fier d'avoir une
équipe
enfin vous inquiétez pas le petit doigt
ne passera pas merci au point faible mon
chou le look franchement talent et était
vraiment à la mode que cap 8 à la
culture c'est de te dire c'est
incroyable on chercherait même à vouloir
aussi mal sammier justement qu'on ne
trouverait pas la boutique je sais même
pas comment tu fais ça un vrai talent du
coup forcément battue c'est l'émission
comment elle est faite c'est un
descrescendo de boutons aujourd'hui je
la vois comme de l'autre côté c'est
gilles pardon mon âge il est ici bas
c'est mon avis et fait un assez bon jean
luc donc voilà c'est comme ça que c'est
fait donc je suis vraiment désolé mais
la télé c'est aussi l'image près de type
ans parfois tu peux arriver comme ça
progresse à pas de sens si avec le look
bon et dans les points forts demain
c'est comme les bonbons c'est ce qui est
important c'est pas l'emballage c'est ce
qu'il ya dedans
d'abord on y arrive à ce qui est dans
mon show à lui on arrive à citer devant
la mairie pour des lui les gens c'est
comme les boues c'est à dire non et donc
le point fort qu'en fait un point faible
j'ai pas trouvé vraiment de points forts
mais fallait remettre en mettre un
c'était scoop a rejoint l'as tu t'es tu
es formidable tu sais que la 27e saison
de lotus c'est toi qui l'annoncé dixième
saison de koh lanta pim encore tous
qu'il a annoncé sixième saison de vos
résultats mais encore toi qu'il annonce
alain franchement et était un génie ce
combat du coup chaque fois contre m
comme note parce que bon franchement tu
es la meute et là tu es programme est ou
n'est pas là moi je t'ai mis la note
médian parce que tu es un garçon médian
je t'aime sac voilà
[Applaudissements]
thierry libérez vous libérez vous c'est
votre immense point faible vous êtes lié
aux puissances de la télévision c'est
vrai comme patron de télé 7 jours vous
ne pouvez rien dire
c'est d'abord un ami des puissants vous
n'osez rien faire libérez-vous comme
dans votre petit costume engoncé que
vous êtes briser vos chaînes une bonne
fois pour toutes pour être vous même
mais vous avez un point fort par est
indémodable
vous savez vous réinventer en permanence
à c'est sûr quand on n'est jamais la
bonne humeur aux blacks sont pourris on
vous met aux chiffres les chiffres sont
nuls vous trouverez autre chose et ça
c'est une force immense honneur et en
direct ses côtés de tous les maux parce
qu'il est à 3-1 il y à l'homme du passé
si vous regardez il ya l'homme du
présent oui vous êtes parfois là et
j'espère pour vous qu'il y aura l'homme
du futur pour ce triple thierry moreau
je mets la magnifique note de 3
ah ben oui je vais dire ce que je pense
de vous comme chaque soir je dis ce que
je pense d'eux de chaque chaque personne
autour de cette table 5
je crois que je merci thierry moreau
alors thierry c'est quelqu'un il le sait
dans la vie je l adore voilà c'est
vraiment mon petit thierry il sait
qu'ils peuvent appeler quand il veut je
serai toujours là pour lui toujours là
pour le soutenir
il sait que je ne le lâcherai jamais
c'est vrai mon titi oui c'est vrai qu'a
tu sais que tu peux compter sur moi
il sait que je laime fort et il est
indispensable dans l'émission voilà
c'est vraiment j'avais très peur pour
thierry moreau je vous le dire au début
d'année parce que c'est vrai que je vous
dis est ce qui va encore retrouvé sa
place tout ça donc j'ai parlé beaucoup
et il a su l'a trouvé grâce à ces
chiffres grâce à son humour grâce à sa
bonne humeur
non mais vraiment il a eu en fait il n'a
pas d'humour il a une bonne humeur c'est
vrai il est toujours de bonne humeur non
mais franchement c'est vrai il est
toujours de bonne humeur
on est toujours content de l'avoir
autour de la table tout le monde l'a
d'or et c'est vrai que c'est un très bon
camarade sur les analyses médias c'est
souvent celui sur lequel je m'appuie
voilà au cours de l'émission parce que
c'est celui qui a le plus d'infos mine
de rien et c'est celui sur voilà sur lui
qui travaille à peu près le plus avec
avec deux trois personnes il s'auto de
la table enfin plutôt une ou deux
personnes autour de la table et mon titi
n'a qu'un seul défaut vous le dis ce
n'est pas son humour c'est qu'il est
patron de télé 7 jours et c'est son
défaut d'être patron télé 7 jours c'est
qu'ils n'osent pas parfois se lâcher sur
telle émission sur tel animateur ce qui
dit après ils vont refuser la couv
ils vont refuser des choses voilà il est
encore dans son groupe de presse et
c'est bien normal et représenter les
sept jours mais c'est vrai qu'il a du
mal un peu a flashé et a à dire tout ce
qu'ils pensent comme il pourrait le
faire en loge parfois y met un petit peu
le frein ici autour de la table voilà
que peur de froisser certaines personnes
et même aujourd'hui regardez on a été
obligé de l'habiller comme ça ce que je
vous dis tout ce qu'il a refusé de se
mettre en jupe à ce qu'il a dit je suis
patron de télé 7 jours et le patron de
télé 7 jours ne se met pas en jupon m1
écoute le patron de télé cède il se met
bien aux chiens voilà mr
je tenais cet ennemi mais mon thierry
moreau parce que je t'aime fort et que
père dit on va voir les notes les plus
tôt cinq 6,5 sur 10 donc très bonne note
pour thierry moreau vous avez 6 sur 10
donc monsieur n'auront les
encouragements vous êtes troisième de la
classe pour l'instant mon titi est ce
que vous avez quelque chose à dire aux
téléspectateurs je voulais vous
remercier g13 de la part de gilles c'est
un magnifique cadeau parce que tu es
extrêmement sévère et voilà merci à tous
et merci à vous pour merci moi tu es tu
allé réponde à sa phase merci qui fut
celle des trophées le cap